hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Google whew the game
where you try to guess what Google is
gonna guess when you're trying to look
at porn unless you're not look at the
porn and if you're not what are you
doing with your life
come on Wells is the internet for so
I'll my favorite categories people and
not any of the other ones I'll do the
other ones to show you what they are but
my favorite is people because they're
relatable human problems that we humans
have to experience in our human lives
with our human limbs never put a dick in
your butt dammit god dammit I told
myself I was gonna start it off this way
never put a question mark where God
never put a hat on your bed never put a
sock in a toaster what the [ __ ] is that
I just said this was hashtag relatable
[ __ ] you're gonna give me this acid
tree [ __ ] off Google how to look
handsome [ __ ] how to look beautiful [ __ ]
how to look hot god I got to know what
the internet wants I got to speak the
internet lingo it's very simplistic
language how to look less stupid how
look cool awesome niblets less stupid
BAM
I'll [ __ ] off how to look older pretty
younger skinny for bedbugs like a model
this is [ __ ] I want to buy a snowman
[ __ ] I wanna buy a car I want to buy a
house I want to buy a dog what am i cat
[ __ ] I wanna buy us sit boy oh boy I
wanna buy a wife
damnit I want to buy a timeshare done
boat time tiny tiny house I wanna buy an
itty bitty house for tiny box Tim living
just a needy baby what it could be a
door woohoo my best friend is us no man
my best friend is an [ __ ] a [ __ ] come
on that makes me look bad
oh no my best friend is a cool guy damn
it is a guy girl who why would you need
to look this up this isn't a Google
worthy phrase alright fine you know
whatever my friends are all dead oh my
god oh my god that was one of them my
friends are all jerks my friends are all
cooler than I am man this is talking
about my friends a lot my friends are
all mean [ __ ] wasted wasted and I hate
this club god I got a thing more
millennial I gotta be more millennial on
this how to draw a snowman stick figure
hand [ __ ] Rose how to get rich off of
stupid people off the internet how to
get rich off your family huh how do you
get rich off of exploiting slave labor
I got spill it right now stocks YouTube
penny stocks [ __ ] best way to kill time
what best way to kill your family its
way to kill your wife damn it I'm
terrible oh my god that was all logical
things was I doing
why was I defaulting to murder I love
the feeling of being huh okay alright
then I love it
taste of dick dammit
wrong both times I love the taste of
blood yeah I love the taste of meat
dammit I who have the taste of all I was
so close Oh on the right track I didn't
know how close I what it is so stupid
it's so stupid I'm sorry that's so
stupid I accidentally ate Jeff Goldblum
that's not how you spell his name damn
it
absolutely Adam Sandler actually 8-ball
oh no I accidentally ate gluten oh [ __ ]
man I think I have an erection hey Vic I
have a tumor I think I have cancer
I think I have a pet names DIY that
really made me laugh I've been very
giggly mood okay I wanna be a snowman I
want to be a marine I wanna be an
engineer
god damnit oh I want to be a millionaire
obvious that's obvious I think I
swallowed the Venus guy swallowed my
lips tea I'm sorry I miss is not funny
it's it's not funny I know this oh man I
know [ __ ] man I'm sorry a nail damn it I
think I swallow and bone piece of glad
that makes no sense what's it like to be
gay
I'd like to be a girl what's it like to
be a fifty god is so not fun Heath it's
so not funny I'm going out of my goddamn
mind when you die you try for real you
die in the game when you die you go to
heaven nothing when you die you go to
hell damn it
and you've time become a tree because of
great beautiful tree
oh man I'm sorry I am so sorry I'm so
sorry for this video I'm sorry for being
a goddamn giggly fool I Anne you can
play this game through the link in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see
more of this let me know I might explore
the other categories but so far people's
my favorite so thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye